what's going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data data
science statistics and programming so
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this if you haven't already and hit
the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so it's been a little while actually
since i have made a video but
i want to talk about one question that
has come up a lot throughout the years
in the data science world which is
if data science is so hot and it is as
people call it the sexiest job of the
21st century why is it so hard to get a
data science job this is certainly an
experience that a lot of people have run
into and
in fact we're just sort of coming out of
this period of the great resignation
where people are sort of hopping more
than they ever have been in the past
from one job to another which includes
data science
but with upcoming fears in the current
macro environment of things like hiring
freezes and layoffs and things like that
i suspect this question is going to come
up a little bit more going forward so i
want to talk about for a lot of people
they really have a hard time finding a
data science job and it's not
necessarily their fault so we're going
to talk about why that why that is and
things that you can do to make it easier
to get that data science job
which you're going to apply regardless
of whether the macro environment is good
or bad
all right so the very first thing that
we're going to talk about here may be a
little blunt but i think it is something
that you need to be very honest with
yourself about
and it's that you just may not have all
the skills that you need to break into
data science
or alternatively you may have skills but
you're finding it difficult to find a
job that is a fit and that is
appropriate for the skills that you do
have and that's a separate topic that
we'll touch on in a little bit here but
i think it's appropriate first to just
start with a refresher on some of the
skills that data scientists out there
actually have
and so this behind me is an article from
katy nuggets they do all kinds of good
polls and surveys and studies about the
pool of data science talent and and the
market out there and this article is a
couple years old but to the best of my
knowledge nothing here has really
changed the big picture here is is still
the same
and so
some of the top skills that data
scientists are reporting that they have
or at least that they want are python
probability and statistics data
visualization
math critical thinking whatever that
means
uh data cleaning or data prep or etl
which is definitely something that
you're going to spend a lot of time
doing in an applied data science a job
and so the main point here is let's say
you're somebody who has only a few of
these skills
it is really going to help you to pick
up some new skills
and i have a video that i made all about
a study pathway for data scientists
where i recommend you start with
probability and statistics then you
learn sql next then you learn one of
python or r and r isn't actually listed
in this top set of skills but it is
definitely going to increase your
employability prospects and open up some
doors for you and ultimately the most
important thing is to learn skills even
if you're not necessarily learning them
in that particular order but again the
most important thing is
if there are certain deficiencies that
you have and certain skills that you're
lacking it is really going to help you
out to focus on yourself first and to
build up those skills and i understand
if you're not already in the data
science job market that can be a little
bit challenging right the very best way
that you can possibly learn a new skill
is to learn it in an applied project
that you're doing in a business context
but there are certainly other resources
available if you're enrolled in college
that's that's a good opportunity there
are tons of courses out there there's
all kinds of free resources
if you don't want to go all the way of
something that's paid
and you can you can read books out there
and once you start learning new things
try and put these things into practice
in some kind of project whether it's in
a kegel setting maybe even a
freelance project
so
ultimately the more that you know the
better off that you're going to be
now having said all of that if you're
somebody who has any skills at all there
are things that you can do with those
skills
and so sort of by definition the data
science job market is sort of going to
demand that you have multiple skills
that's
just kind of the nature of the beast
now there are jobs out there that demand
that you be perfect unicorns and you
really shouldn't worry about those
regardless of your skill level
but
now i look at data science as the
intersection between statistics
programming communication and business
or domain knowledge now granted
everybody's going to have a little bit
of deficiency in at least one of those
areas maybe you have weaknesses in two
or even three of those areas but there
are still jobs that you can look for
that match the skills that you have
so this is an article here from towards
data science and i'm not going to go
through every single one of these but
honestly i think every single one of
these has at least some kind of overlap
with the skills that you use in the
day-to-day and data science and so just
to go through one example here
let's suppose you're somebody who
maybe you don't know python but you do
know r
you're a little bit weak on machine
learning but she knows a lot of
conventional probability and statistics
and maybe even things like survival
analysis or biostats or epidemiology and
things of that nature
it may just be appropriate for you to
look for job title statistician and just
not sweat the difference between what's
a statistician and what's a data
scientist
similarly with like a business analyst
maybe you're somebody who communicates
pretty well you know data visualization
you know the particular business that
you're trying to go into but you're a
little bit weaker on the technical and
mathematical stuff a business analyst
may be a perfect starting point for you
and from that point like i said there is
going to be overlap here between these
roles and a traditional data science
role and so it could be a good starting
point for you just to find a job like
this build skills up there maybe try and
leverage opportunities you have in a job
like one of these to learn new skills
and then leverage that towards becoming
some kind of data scientist or maybe
even senior data scientists down the
road
and so now i want to shift gears away
from talking about the skills that you
have to being able to properly
communicate those skills because i think
this is something that a lot of data
scientists really struggle with that's
actually the very next point in this
article and there's another article here
from towards data science that's
does a pretty good job laying out the
fact that even people with master's and
phd level education this is something
that they really struggle with because
the things that are important in
business is a really big shift away from
the things that you spend your
day-to-day thinking about and doing in
the academic world
and so
in the business world nobody cares
really at all about this amazing uh
beautiful xg boost model that you
created and just how technically
sophisticated it is they care about how
that provides value to their business
and increases the revenue of that
business sorry to be blunt about it but
it really is the truth
and so
a technique that i really recommend for
just about anybody is what's known as
the storyboard technique and that means
you're telling a story about the things
that you've done in the past it starts
with just providing an overall view of
the landscape so a 30 000 or 10 000 feet
uh
view of the business and the context
then you move into the specific problem
that you're trying to solve the solution
that you came up with to that problem
and then the impact and now in a lot of
circumstances it's not possible to lay
out every single one of these things and
that's especially difficult if you're
coming fresh out of school um it's a lot
more difficult to talk about things like
kangal projects or projects that you've
worked on in school but this is
definitely a mindset that you want to be
thinking about especially if you're
somebody who already has experience out
there you're not just fresh out of
school
but just speaking more broadly here and
going beyond just what these different
job titles call themselves
there is just a huge breadth of
different skills out there in the data
science world
and so it's really impossible for you to
be qualified for every job that's out
there
you really do need to put in the effort
and find a job that's appropriate for
you and that goes for any kind of skill
level even if you want to stick to
strictly jobs that call themselves data
scientists and so that means really
reading the descriptions of these jobs
before you apply them figuring out does
it look like this is an appropriate fit
for you
maybe even something that you could do
is
if you're searching for a job on
something like linkedin or indeed or
something like that
let's say you know sql or r and you want
to lean into those skills search for sql
data scientists or our data scientists
and just just see what you find and so
now i want to shift gears away from
talking about the skills that you have
to being able to properly communicate
those skills because i think this is
something that a lot of data scientists
really struggle with that's actually the
very next point in this article and
there's another article here from
towards data science that's
does a pretty good job laying out the
fact that even people with master's and
phd level education this is something
that they really struggle with because
that's things that are important in
business is a really big shift away from
the things that that you spend your
day-to-day thinking about and doing in
the academic world
and so
in the business world nobody cares
really at all about this amazing uh
beautiful xg boost model that you
created and just how technically
sophisticated it is they care about how
that provides value to their business
and increases the revenue of that
business sorry to be blunt about it but
it really is the truth
and so
a technique that i really recommend for
just about anybody is what's known as
the storyboard technique and that means
you're telling a story about the things
that you've done in the past
it starts with just providing an overall
view of the landscape so thirty thousand
or ten thousand feet uh
view of the business and the context
then you move into the specific problem
that you're trying to solve the solution
that you came up with to that problem
and then the impact and now in a lot of
circumstances it's not possible to lay
out every single one of these things
and that's especially difficult if
you're
coming uh fresh out of school um it's a
lot more difficult to talk about things
like kangal projects or projects that
you've worked on in school but this is
definitely a mindset that you want to be
thinking about especially if you're
somebody who already has experience out
there you're not just fresh out of
school
so again you do need to proactively sell
the skills that you have and a lot of
that really comes down to focusing not
on the theoretical or technical aspects
of the work that you have done but on
how those things can add value to a
business or two to different business
problems
and a related issue to this it's
different but it is related is really
being able to sell yourself
so again that means speaking to the
skills that you have being confident in
the skills that you have even if you
aren't truly confident there is at least
some some truth to the old cliche that
you fake it until you make it and so how
you communicate and talk about yourself
really really makes a difference but
then creating a portfolio this is
something that especially a lot of
inexperienced uh people trying to get
into data science don't do and even if
you start with a very super simple basic
github portfolio with a few things that
you did in college anything is better
than nothing and shows that you're
making strides in the right direction
so the final point i'm going to talk
about in this video it's another aspect
of a typical data science interview
process
has to do with them giving you an
assessment and so what i'm specifically
referring to here is not
whiteboarding sessions which that's
something separate that you may have to
do
but rather your interviewer gives you
some kind of take-home assessment so
it's some kind of business problem
usually of a machine learning a context
and they ask you to put some solution or
some model together and then you'll send
it back to them and often at the end you
have to get some kind of presentation on
it
so
this is a pretty common practice and it
is something that a lot of people
struggle with
so
i'm going to let you in on a little
secret with these things just having
done a lot of these myself and having
been on the other end having done
multiple of these uh and seeing other
people submit them
a lot of data science and hr departments
who go through this process have no idea
what they're doing i say that because
a lot of them often give you absolutely
unrealistic estimates of how much time
it'll take like they may tell you it'll
take two or four hours and then by the
end of the day it takes 10 to 15 hours
and it may be a pretty technically
competent person who goes over and reads
these but they don't really actually
know what they're looking for when
they're trying to evaluate you and so
another thing that that they won't tell
you is that a lot of people they just
can't get through these at all that is
some people will just filter themselves
out of the process because they'll go
look for another job that's not asking
them to do a take-home assessment just
to just to try to save time that way but
then there's a lot of people who just
cannot get through these things at all
and they just turn in solutions that are
terrible and so
i say this in part for motivational
reasons just to inspire you
just get through this assessment and so
it may be helpful for you to pick up a
book like
say hands-on machine learning with a
second learn
or r for data science or a book like
that and find a similar problem that's
out there maybe copy some code chunks
here and there and work with them
organize your your your thoughts and the
work that you've done and your solution
into a notebook because they may also
try to gauge your presentation skills
and again if if they're good for you
that's another thing that's going to set
you apart so again it all comes down to
if you have some kind of take-home
assessment just do your research
find
solutions out there that are similar and
try and work work with those if you
don't know what you're doing and just
get through this because it really does
turn into a numbers game if you do
enough of these i promise you eventually
you're going to move forward in one of
the processes you're going through
so i think these are some overarching
reasons people sometimes struggle to
find a data science job which have been
true even in the case of the
relatively good macro environment that
we've been in for the last decade or so
and the whole true maybe even more so
even if we're to go into a slower macro
environment and so what i would
encourage somebody who's trying to break
into data science is that again you
don't want to be somebody unless you're
in a super desperate personal situation
you don't want to be somebody who's just
applying every single place where
there's an opening because quite frankly
there's all kinds of jobs out there that
are not going to be appropriate for you
that's not that's not a you problem
that's just a nature of the market that
we're in and how just broad and diverse
data science can be so
again i i want to stress a point that i
made earlier in the video which is you
really want to focus on yourself and
develop yourself the more that you've
done that the more experience you've
gained and the more skills you have the
easier this is going to get and once you
once you really break into data science
the first time it just gets easier from
there you just need to do it and then
you're going to be in good shape from
there on out
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it once again smash the like
button leave me a comment down below and
let me know did you have a difficult
time breaking into data science are you
going through some of those struggles
right now let me know then i'll see you
all in the not so distant future until
then
richard on data